elle n'était pas destinée à être reine
et pourtant elisabeth windsor devenu
elizabeth 2 aura eu le plus long règne
de l'histoire né à londres le 21 avril
1926 elle était la troisième dans
l'ordre de succession après son oncle et
son père une enfance qui semble plutôt
gai
à 13 ans elle rencontre le prince philip
de grèce et c'est le coup de foudre
lorsque la seconde guerre mondiale
éclate
elisabeth son rôle comme apprenti
conductrice d'ambulance et comme
mécanicienne
à 21 ans elle se révèle lors de son
discours à cape town en afrique du sud
où elle dédie sa vie à la monarchie
je déclare devant vous dit elle que je
me dévoue entièrement à vous et à notre
grande famille impériale
sept mois plus tard elle épouse philippe
mamba tonnes qui devra renoncer ses
titres royaux grecs et danois le mariage
aura duré 74 ans et ne prendra fin qu'à
la mort du prince en avril 2021
c'est en 1950 durant une visite
officielle au kenya que la princesse
apprend la mort de son père elle devient
alors reine mary ford
matthew
etherington
locale
le couronnement est célébré à l'abbaye
de westminster elisabeth n'a que 26 ans
et devient elizabeth 2
en moins de six mois la reine se rend
dans les caraïbes au moyen-orient en
afrique elle verra l'éclatement de
l'empiré britannique
l'indépendance des anciennes colonies
qui deviennent est un membre du
commonwealth
10 qui arbitre a été son secrétaire
privé pendant douze ans
a sombré
à
son jubilé la reine réitère son serment
rose va opposer made in mice à la baisse
même si ce serment a été prononcé il ya
longtemps dit elle je ne regrette rien
je regrette la retraite
un dévouement à la vie publique certes
mais plutôt absente comme mère de
famille décriront plusieurs
très difficile d'être chefs d'état et
mère de famille sous l'indycar beacher
on lui reproche d'avoir été plus
préoccupés par les affaires de l'état
toute la famille
je sais
ce sont surtout les affaires familiales
qui font la une des journaux il ya eu le
mariage très royale de son fils le
prince charles avec lady diana en 1981
un véritable conte de fées au tout
semble réussir
aux deux fils william et harry mais
quelques années plus tard le couple se
sépare en 1996 c'est le divorce la
princesse terne la seule fille de la
reine divorce également après avoir eu
ses deux enfants et le prince andrew se
sépare aussi sa femme sarah ferguson la
monarchie devient de plus en plus
impopulaire la reine des cris 1992 comme
sa pire année ses deux fils se séparent
de leurs femmes et le château de windsor
et détruit par un incendie
58 eur en 1997 la mort tragique de la
princesse diana bouleverse tout le pays
la reine est absente elle est dans sa
résidence de balmoral avec son mari et
ses petits fils le public ne comprend
pas la popularité de la monarchie est à
son plus bas la reine seront alors à
londres et livre un discours en direct
diffusée sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision
les années pas si la reine reconquiert
le coeur des anglais elle n'a plus à ses
côtés sa mère la reine mère et sa soeur
la princesse margaret
[Musique]
le prince charles se remarie avec son
amour de jeunesse camilla parker bowles
la vie continue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
son jubilé de diamant est célébrée sur
la tamise 10 millions de britanniques
eux rendent hommage pour souligner ses
60 ans de règne
[Musique]
ici
la dignité et avec quelle nature
et ça c'est parfait pour
exécuter les rockets doit faire elle est
très réservé
dans les émotions et ça peut-être
est aussi bas avant avant de trash tout
son temps pour dire qu'elle leur assurer
une continuité une stabilité malgré les
coups durs
en 2019 son fils cadet le prince un jour
doit faire face à la justice car il est
soupçonné d'agressions sexuelles sur une
mineure en janvier 2020 son petit fils
harry quitte la famille royale avec sa
femme megan à cause de la pression
médiatique et de l'ambiance anxiogène au
palais la reine suit la devise anglaise
à la lettre keep calm and carry
[Musique]
mais son coup le plus dur sera
certainement la mort du prince philip le
9 avril 2021 quelques jours avant ses 95
ans
elle perd son compagnon de toujours son
confident ce sera une des dernières
photos officielles du couple
la reine continuera à régner gardera
cette place particulière dans le coeur
des britanniques
car ils n'auront connu quelques hommes
york
ce sera un règne sur deux siècles et une
vie guidée par le devoir
[Musique]